hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar little and large using
the flexibility of the mo flow asterisk
EQ from sorting bacteria through the
more classic blood and human cells
through to plant protoplasts I am Judy
O'Rourke of lab routes and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by Beckman Coulter
life sciences Beckman Coulter life
sciences develops manufactures and
markets products that simplify automate
and innovate complex pharmaceutical
quality control testing more than
275,000 Beckman culture systems operate
in both diagnostic and life sciences
laboratories on seven continents for
over 75 years our products have been
making a difference in people's lives by
improving compliance and reducing cost
of ownership to learn more about Beckman
Coulter life sciences please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers in tation
just click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
present to these speakers peter o'toole
PhD and karen Hogg PhD
DRO tool serves as director of the
bioscience technology facility at the
university of york as the head of
imaging and cytometry labs and as vice
president of the royal microscopical
society
he gained a PhD in the cell bio Physics
Laboratory and Essex and has been
involved in many aspects of fluorescence
imaging and cytometry dr. O'Toole's
research is focused on both technology
and method development of novel probes
and imaging modalities his lab provides
research support to many academics and
commercial organizations and he has
ongoing collaborations and consultancy
contracts with many leading microscopy
and cytometry companies dr. o tools
complete bio is found on the lab routes
website dr. Hogg is an experimental
officer for imaging and cytometry at the
University of York's bioscience
technology facility she underpins the
scientific service within the imaging
and cytometry laboratory and takes a
lead role in the research operation and
method development of cell sorting and
analysis dr. Hogg's expertise is tapped
for a wide range of diverse applications
both within and external to the
Department of Biology dr. Hogg obtained
a PhD from the school of biology at the
University of Leeds in the UK and she
received the Royal microscopical Society
medal for flow cytometry in 2016 her
complete bio is also found on the
labyrinth website the speakers will now
begin their presentations thank you for
that Judy that was most flattering so
welcome throughout the presentation and
so as you can see from the title this is
little enlarged I'm little she's large
always it the other way around I'm not
quite sure which we hope this will be
engaging we're going to make me submit
more discussing as we talk through it's
even between ourselves to try and keep
it engaged and to hopefully address many
of these different aspects that you're
interesting Thank You culture for asking
us to do this that is educational
although it's a call to product and we
have
lots of things as we go through it so
the mode flow that we have here isn't a
multi-discipline department and we will
be looking at all sorts of different
sample types doesn't matter what sample
type you have
it'll be relevant to most applications
to yourselves so actually I'd like to
introduce a bit more about ourselves
because if you understand the setting we
are in you probably understand better
why we've actually gotten a Flowmaster
EOS as well and and all the different
drivers and why we have to look at many
different sample types so every part of
my SIA technology facility is actually
I've got here on this bike 22 dedicated
research scientist so just there the
service
now that we are technologists we are
dekes in a cytometry or imaging or in
the other labs as you can see mr.
Fleming's proteomics genomics in
bioinformatics protein production
molecular interactions and so forth but
that's what we really engage ourselves
into so the department that we based in
the exam primary service site has all
sorts of pretty much every branch of
biology that you can imagine I say
branch because that'd be the plant
biology so of course because they they
have branches you'll keep up with it I
think watching this on a Friday far more
entertaining but we obviously have got
the ones that are really infectious you
know the scientists that look at
infection and immunity we have the ones
that really buggers thermicon huh not me
but the microbiologist they really bug
us come on us be keeping up with this at
this point and we've got ones that grow
on us you know the stem cell
developmental biologists point is we
have lots and lots of different users
and with those different users we also
have to serve the external users so we
are an open access facility anyone can
come use the expertise and our
instruments so the instruments need to
be as diverse as possible to cope with
that demand they're saying it's not just
our own academic spirit academics from
other other departments other
institutions all together from all over
the world and also in commercial
companies and we do a huge amount we're
teaching today but actually huge amount
of short delegates as bad courses as
well that burn that hands-on courses
every January in June as well as the
wrong microscopical society course in
September all dedicated to flow
cytometry
now you'll see from the previous slide
though there was a street this is by our
previous director before I took the hell
John Poole who made this night and
you'll see he put imaging and cytometry
at the top of all those other
technologies and there's good reason for
that I'd like to introduce this now
because I think this we have a good
take-home message at the end that brings
us back together to realize why
cytometry is so important so some would
argue that you know mix is the number
one technology still obviously we would
definitely disagree with that because
even though now we can we know the human
genome we've got great new technology
developments it means we can do things
really far to make now identify what's
being upregulated what's being
downregulated we can see what you what
disease you might have in the future but
even if the RNA has been synthesized
inside a cell doesn't mean it's
transcribing the protein of interest
which means ultimately we don't know if
it means anything at all biologically
relevant so do you know mix therefore at
this stage I would say is limited maybe
may be limited I will live with that for
the moment but I haven't proteomics now
that's how experiments they say don't
worry Pete we can take those cells of
interest with your RNA that's been
expressed and we can identify and seems
that protein is actually being
transcribed into cell however just
because the protein is present doesn't
mean it's correctly folded localized in
correct place
how's it relevant cofactors present so
it doesn't mean it's functionally
relevant so even armed sorry proteomics
lab even you not redundant I would say
we done did that be too strong a word I
think they'd kill me at that point but
again good work but now my neighborhood
molecular interaction to say hey hey
Pete
I can now purify that protein of
interest and put it into a course you
bet I mean that warts - bet I can do my
analysis I can look at my enzymatic
activities I can look at my protein
protein interactions I say hey hey you
are now in a cuvette not inside a living
cell and so at that point it really
relevant which is why microscopy don't
forget I've run an imaging and
microscopy lab as my call
service as well microscopy I can
actually see that the protein is in the
cell I can see if it's localized to the
correct place I can look doing fret frat
flip flap and Flint there's a lot of
poor letter F words associated
fluorescence microscopy thank you
another four-letter word add please
don't ultimate there may be people who
can hear you but we can see those
dynamic interaction inside and living
scenario however microscopy this is
gonna kill me it's also limited because
a picture may be able to say a thousand
words a flow cytometer can give you a
million data points making it
statistically relevant run just looking
at one or two cells so all you cytometry
is tuning today well that we are the
best but better still we can now use a
cell sorter which can take us to there
all those other own leaks and I'll show
you at the end while and that's so
important to why actually what I just
said is a load of rubbish and the other
technologies are actually really cool so
let me move on to the lab itself we were
integrating we have flow cytometry
electron microscopy in the advanced
presence imaging advanced light imaging
- leaving quantitative base detuning to
the next webinar on the side flex you
will hear a lot more about the imaging
side as well and its contents but not
only do we have the survey side in the
lab and also involved in a lot of
research and development within that lab
itself and so we have all those
different technologies sitting together
from the flow to the imaging see
electron microscopy so we can see how it
all fits into the bigger picture and
cell sorting is really important to
underpin all of that so the lab we
actually we started in 2002 can join me
I think in beginning of 2003 carrots
being with me for most that time not
with me as you working for me that can
sound kind of inappropriate
no don't misconstrued so we started with
a heap of different equipment and then
to 2018 I should say 18 at top I
apologize we now have expanded
significantly because cytometry has seen
you
explosion of activity and need amongst
the bioscience community and with that
so has the lab throw it so that brings
us onto the Mayflower stereos and we
actually run the EQ system here at York
now I would argue that this is an
example of fine example of American
engineering at this point in from a
British side we also do engineering get
in tune into side flex you'll see what
we do it's elegant and simple pretty
good to use and talk about that later
efficient inquires being signal-to-noise
here and it is a well leader in our
opinion for the top-end
type of sorter but it is still the cell
sorter now that's it so yeah don't get
ahead of ourselves what really attracts
is what we really look at but because we
work in this multi-disciplined
department of biology it's just a sheer
number of sampling types we need to
access ok we have those listed up you
know from the blood cells that come to
sell to the tissue samples to the plants
are bacteria to the yeast to the
parasites to the pollen the question
mark is pretty much anything someone
throw at us
other examples not but is a pretty dirty
one to think about so really we have
done some quite extreme cell sorting in
the past so when choosing a cell sorter
we have to think about many important
aspects such as sterility which is
really important a lot of these sample
types will come to some work - examples
in a few slides time we need to think
about the nozzles that we have readily
available it's important that we got
small nozzles pure yeast your bacteria
through to the large nozzle size if your
megakaryocytes trust me they're sticky
things it can be very large treat to
your plant protoplast and pollen grains
i see they can be quite sizable so we
need larger nozzles to cope with that
speed
patching a lot of these samples when
they get to the site ometer we need to
sort them really fast because they've
got a sharp knife themselves so speed is
very important six way sorting a lot of
people ask is how many six based sorts
do we use fairly bare people quite often
even if it's just for purity and
the enriched population we can do
simultaneously through to learning it
really no pressures if you're using
plant protoplasts these are like air and
balloons filled water filled balloons
you drop them they smash really easily
they're not used to being liberated from
the rest of the plant so I'm happy
really gentle with some of the sample
types course with stem cells million
carry sights we want to do 96-well
vector or even greater than 96 both
based sorting will give an example of
that and near the end of this
presentation as well so actually we'll
skip over that slide I'd like to give
you a worked example so actually I get
the first one the first one okay you can
see this is well prepared we kind of we
are a tag-team I should point out as
well we're not the only tag-team Graham
and Canada also work with another Cavins
two counts and Graham he's not a Canon
who also work with us at the facility
and we all pass the self-taught team so
actually they all have big inputs into
the work and the results that you'll see
through this so the first one is
actually tumor cells this is a normal
maintenance group you do a lot of this
and and Collins has been instrumental in
lots of this work as well
funding we prostrate cancer research in
the UK with mostly so this is really
important that for a lot of their tumor
cells we have to be moved contaminating
cells which means resolution about
fluorescence intensity to isolate those
populations is important purity I think
in most cases is vital for almost
everything this is getting a common
theme of purity to variety we don't want
contaminating cells getting into that
post analysis multiple parameters when
these are stem cells and so we're gonna
you have to throw a load of markers to
exclude cells not an interest actually a
speed yield you can see those actually
for this case total stability is really
important these cells are not going to
be able to see antibiotics host cell
source are we gonna have antibiotic free
processing culturing of these cells host
sort and Louise and these are going to
be rejected
after this time as well so ethically
this has to be absolutely perfect
throughout this so if we look at what
they've been doing with it they will
take normal biopsy samples from a
prostate and the cancer biopsies they'll
then digest these samples into single
cell suspensions which will then use a
cell sorter to sort through so this is
just a crude example of all the data
that they have it's obviously a lot more
complex as we go through it but we can
sort out the different populations
to give us a luminal better data base
ourselves our normal tumor cells to the
prostate then we'll then use those
sorted cells to do transcriptomic
analysis so we've taken a per cell
sorter through to the genomics
transcriptomic lab to do our analysis of
those salty cells to find out which
sounds are most relevant and to try and
start to understand the differences
between the different populations we're
seeing through the cell plate at four
through cell analyses through flow
cytometry and through cell sorting but
not only that we want to phenotype the
cells to a greater degree so we're
actually then take them onto the
confocal it's the fluorescence and the
confocal microscopes and start looking
at the protein patterning their
localization because you see the
proteins we can identify high
expressives versus and low Express's
using flow cytometry but what that
doesn't tell us is a localization of
these and so actually we can sell all
these and just put the straight onto the
microscope no need to do it all sewn on
taneous Lee we can look at them and we
can start to look at their past ink and
start to add more complex studies -
thank you sister
phenotyping through immunofluorescence
fluorescence imaging really can now take
themselves the counter cells and normal
cells the luminal cells cancer luminal
cells and we can do our transcriptome
analysis we can also then follow them
over time and wait for differentiation
of these we can then do further analysis
so we can look at celebration we could
look at locomotion tracking of cells
over time we do a lot of that actually
said this is really encompassing almost
most allow
in the technology facilities do a lot of
these studies so to to our self in
oppression but this is I love this image
if you look at the bottom images these
cells really differentiate into very
different phenotypes of the cells not
always evidence you can't see these
easily just by doing fluorescence
labeling but looking at the quality of
these Alex is using a technique called
quantitative phase imaging to place
focus you can see the different
populations and phenotype in great
detail so great we now understand the
cells we can isolate the cells but now
let's put them back let's treat them put
them back into the patient's that point
we can then follow me to overtime and
can we harvest the cells at the end from
that we can now look to change our
studies and we can see what's happened
with our treated and our non-treaty
cells
well Shorty's the non-treaty cells we
get more tumors throughout 226 days
there's a lot of mice for the tree T
cells that are still tumor free after
120 days so it's a fax the cell sorting
but starts all the way through the
process
so we sort we do our transcript omics we
do our imaging phenotypic information we
come to them we can be in check back
into patients and then bring them back
out and again at the end and the game we
can do our flow analysis and through
cell sorting again we can then do our
transcriptomic vomits have a low me and
proteomic analysis of those same cells
we got all the way through so really
because of that process you can see
those populations are not so distinct
sometimes the resolutions really
important purity is negative importance
because these are antibiotic free
remember and we also look at many
parameters now at E so you should have
prompted me on this speed is an issue
because actually Carol I'll ask you when
they come and ourselves how long do they
have before they before the cells start
to not become too happy well it varies
from sample types up on site we can keep
them at 4 degrees if that would keep
themselves happier for longer but at
certain point it's going to be viability
issues so
to get them back to where they need to
be as quick as we can and for the
prostate since these are human patients
cells so coming straight from the human
patients and Germany they want these
sorted within a couple of hours of
coming out to the patients which is a
quick turnaround time so reliability and
speed is really important now next work
two example is a parasite so actually
I'm going to take a coffee and let
Cameron talk about this problem okay so
this was some work that we did with some
twenty same parasites and this one again
resolution was really important as we
needed to make sure that we obtained the
correct cells for the downstream
application and the purity needs to be
there as well for this one we also
needed to culture the parasites only for
a short period of time but you still
need to make sure that there's no bugs
in there that shouldn't be there and
time was really critical for this
experiment because we could only sort
them for an hour before we then needed
to call it day and move on to the next
sample and the yield was important as
well because if you haven't got enough
data points you haven't got enough for
each of those culture experimental sets
so here is a plot of some of the data
from the main three westeros and there's
a little screenshot there above a
parasite from the bright field image as
well so these are fairly small that
they're elongated so we used a log log
system for our scatter properties for
our cordon side scatter but we were able
to put a single it gate on there to make
sure we haven't got two parasite stuck
together which would affect our purity
because the two cells they might
separate after the sort now for this
experiment our sort criteria who's
looking for cell cycle stages so G 1 and
s stroke G 2 and that's shown by the
plot on the side and with the 405 area
axis and the major peak can see there is
the G 1 and then the s G 2 is that the
hump to the site and then the next slide
here it can show that their single
parameter histogram doesn't give you
such a good detail as a dot plot which
is the plot to the side with the boxes
mark g1 s g2 and hee
see with the density pot with the two
parameters you can identify those cell
cycle phases the density block
definitely helps resolve 13 yes I would
be good better data no because we're
imaging and cytometry we could take
these sorted parasites and put them on
the microscope to verify using my
morphology that they were in their g1
and s stroke g2 phases using the
position of the nucleus and the commute
applies which also contains DNA material
we're able to make sure that these sort
gains gave us the correct data but then
what we wanted to do with these was
culture them for longer and we needed to
make sure that the g1 and s sort of
parasites were correct so we post sorted
them by putting them back Mowgli to go
alongside the microscopy data and that's
what you can see on the posts or plots
that no salt gate has been one that's
slightly after sorting but typically you
do that because you get a normal
distribution off your saw okay you can
definitely see those ships in those
class that's okay I'm just looking there
at the post s stroke g2 and there's
definitely a cloud the kind of is there
you can see it's quite cool can you
comment on why you've got some just
outside the gate there well I think
that's very likely because of the cells
that were in S or g2 during that sort
time of transition through to g1 which
is why that time point was really
critical of an hour because if we spent
three hours sorting we might have more
of those cells that have gone back
through into g1 so what did they look
like after sorting we can see that this
or purity is good for microscopy and
from place light on the tree but were
they still viable were they still able
to transition through their cell cycle
phases so over a six hour culture period
no sorting the parasites were then
cultured and they were taken out at
various time points which is shown in
the black text boxes one hour through to
six hour in the plots to see it
what they did and so this first slide
here is the g1 soldiered cells and you
can see as the time frame goes through
that the parasites are able to move from
g1 through to s g2 over that time period
so these are a lot sharper here than
they were before yogi shake a hump on
the sliders it was a hump on the slide
before he's never got quite distinct g2
population comment on Windows so on the
previous slide they were using a cell
permeant DNA done like that whereas here
the cells have been taken out of culture
and they've been fixed and then they've
been stained with the DNA binding die
which is propidium iodide which is why
it's a further red shifted detection
channel that makes sense and also the
site on which is different because I
didn't put these back through the moat
flow this was an analysis state so this
station was actually done on the side
flexors and so we've got different
detectors as well Society pencils got
IEDs and the moment yeah accessorize for
the NPD's of the islands most guys who
detect is actually again I'm talking
about a size place system in the next
webinar coming up soon as showing why
the resolution is that much better
compared to other side Thomas you don't
get any vision in cell sorters not yeah
yes
let's hope someone will do that so
that's it that certainly explains why so
much to me to most tie in I presume that
just looking at that top left one but
you've got some are winning g2 I guess
that's the same answers before we sort
of achieve do you want but they're
already going into cycle by the time we
got some time zero case it still takes
time to go from sorter a spun-out media
and and so therefore they could by
they've transitioned this is quite
exciting so we do a lot of limiting
which reconnaissance as well and
actually they're really fragile so they
died really easily they're not they're
not happy to not be in their native
environment so the fact they could still
cycling quite easily shows actually
we're sorting quite gently he's actually
not doing them any harm so it's quick
enough and gentle enough to actually
keep these things get any happy
and because because at that point we
chose to use them the 90 micron nozzle
with 30 psi even though they're small to
hopefully enable the viability to be as
good as we'd like it to be at the angel
zone so the next slide shows a similar
profile but with the estro g2 sorted
parasite zone and are they able to
transition from that end of cell cycle
background into G 1 and then go further
forward so the first plot shows majority
of cells in G 2 and we have got a little
bit in G 1 and we just specify that
little peak is there but you can see
that they are able to move forward and
round through to g1 and I think by the
6:00 hour some have gone back through
into G 2 again so we were happy with
this sort methodology to then move
forward with some more experimental data
that the researcher wants to do with
that with this this system so from the
summary from from network to example the
resolution was important we need a good
purity because if we've got
contaminating cells that's going to
affect the downstream data we needed
sterility speed was important but
further slightly different reasons and
the yield is also you always want to get
as much back as you can to have
available to do the work that you want
to want to utilize yes I actually said
it isn't actually on their lobbies
taking these our trip and Zoe's season
adventures yes yeah okay and Carol
annoying I still here
so actually for for not just ability of
the sample but also keeping us safe he's
rather be important for some of these
sample types and so obviously that's
another important aspect and sources to
be able to actually keeping the operator
safe at all times as well so just one of
them aspect that it's not aerosol
generated so you have a well so we're
allowed to breathe yes that's good cool
okay so we are a multi-discipline
department and it works example number
tweens plant throw two plus two Z so you
can see I'm not a plant biologist at all
and actually I think he's a psycho
mitrice week eating flow cytometry
doesn't matter why
Lennie's we need to be able to turn our
hand pretty much any type of application
mark ray blasts are really difficult one
to use it they're out there a bit out
there when it comes to being edgy for
self sorting so now you're talking large
so these may be 40 microns yeah as I
said earlier they like a water-filled
balloon now really they've got no people
sell wool now take it away so these are
they're not yeah what difficulties yeah
so my pressures large nozzle sizes are
really important what we really like to
make mark raise prices are our
utilization of autofluorescence because
actually processing itself create loads
of debris there's lots of fatalities on
roots to getting these plants to little
cell sorts to start with and so we have
to be able to identify the intact cells
over everything else an auto presence
came to our rescue that it's a pre yeah
plant biology's we've always complained
about our so much autofluorescence only
in the fog red in the fire bed okay so
we now have a free fluorescent channel
we can use to our advantage
so county want to talk to you a nice
light on the way to talk through this so
so again we've got some locals showing
us Pete's already mentioned in the first
plot with all events the scatter
properties I mean that is a mess the
amount of debris that's there we need to
be able to identify the protoplast from
from that fallout the processing and the
autothrust when the chlorophyll can be
seen in the next plot along so at about
750 but also presents us quite good
emission profile you can pick it up in
many of the red channels you can see
that we've got a peak there that she's
got very high intensity and that's
showing the chloroplasts in intact
protoplast so an intact protoplast will
have the mass when mamantov and Clarabel
present within it well that was our
premise then yeah if you look at the
intensity of those intact
that the walnut stripped out to the
third plot along you've got a thing in
the box it says it's a crater but if you
look at the intensity of that and then
the population just below it they are
single chloroplasts and actually the
intensity of the in tat ones around six
to eight
greater than the singles which
correlates really nicely when you put
lender might go it's the number of
chloroplasts are actually in an intact
cell so you can also use that intensity
to identify how many chloroplasts that
are ourselves we can look at the high
number of compatibility cells with lower
numbers of chloroplasts as well so we've
used it for umpteen reasons that's why
statement I think we did a fair bit of
chewing broken microscope to prove this
your first time we did it to have a look
at the caress ins with the or take
fluorescence and make sure that our
premise actually the only worked so then
we can gate on the intact protoplast and
then i've just put them as scatter
properties those intact protoplasts as a
final plot on this slide and you can see
how that clearly gets away from all the
temporary walls and stuff on the lower
corner has disappeared but they are
quite a diverse bunch I mean that's
quite a lot of scatter and fills the
screen there so you know we're not
getting a pinpoint of sample it's quite
a lot of biological variability in there
so what we were interested in this is
then taking these protoplasm looking at
their green fluorescent protein their
GFP content so we were able to use a
single gate to make sure we didn't have
to do protoplasts again that's fairly
unlikely but we checked it anyway and
then we can sort our GFP negative and
our GFP positive cells and again we
chose to use a dot plot which in our
hands is always better than using a
single parameter histogram for most
swords and so we're able to sort these
populations out and then these
protoplast went through to further omics
analysis and the paper was published and
the reference there is in the plant
journal if you want to have a look at
more details as to what actually
happened to these these these protons
it's not about the cytometry in that
journal really it's about what the study
was for many of you have got a cell
sorters that any wanting to call out
actually you know what we do is only a
small component of a bigger picture yes
really it's a vital component because
without it they're stuck so you know I'm
really proud of any
yes publication anything about academics
we help get to their end results that
that's really important and so our
instruments are key for achieving that
so really that large nozzle size
actually enables a low-pressure city
school attending doesn't it so in this
case that's probably the most key
aspects fundamentals to make sure how
big of a nozzle we can actually get to
news to enable in this type of research
to be done which isn't always possible
on every salt in the market at the
moment
who this will really buggy buggy there's
a matter ok grows on you doesn't it
these puns eventually this is example
number number four and actually you
people for me here it's divinity game
not necessarily to get the sample pure
at the end with stability because the
next user maybe that prostate cancer
group and they are going to need
absolute stability and then I said what
was it look what am I just use before
bacteria you can imagine the look of
horror on their faces when they know
bhakti was put into the same cell sorter
so being able to clean it he's just
absolutely vital to be able to give a
good sterile like sterile instruments
even after working with things that you
can theme would be the worst thing you
could possibly do but that's what we do
takes a bit of effort but I think we can
come to you in Q&A session yeah if
anyone's interested and have you
sterilize it so Cameron actually my
coffees really good so I'll good that
you thought talking way through this
like they're nothing okay so this was an
experiment using Salmonella as our folks
and we wanted to use the backlight assay
to identify their life and the dead
bacteria and so we looked into the
protocol for this and you know it curly
states you can get live and dead
populations but then in even in the
protocol them in so she it says you've
got this unknown population well
scientists don't generally like
unknown populations so we decided that
we wanted to sort for the populations
that we can see on the place like Tom
enter and work out which rely which were
dead and
the unknowns live or dead because this
was key to the some of the questions
that were being asked because we wanted
to know did the unknown ones transition
through to the dead zone or the light
zone and this unit can be important for
interpreting data down down the line so
this is an example of the flow clock
that we got from salmonella with this
back light kit and you can see that
we've got well you can just about see
both populations so the bottom
[Music]
population here is number one so that's
a bottomless and that's the green ones
and then slightly higher green
fluorescent but a little bit rectangle
on the right-hand side yeah so it's it's
the high green but it's starting to be a
little bit red was the second population
and we called those live low and live
high and then we had an intermediate
population which has got more red
fluorescence but still a little bit of
green and then we've got a triangle yeah
and then we've got the ones that we've
termed dead and they have got high red
fluorescence and they're starting to
lose their green because the the site oh
nine which gives the green fluorescence
is quenched by the medium iodide and so
those were the those were the
populations that we sorted so what did
we what did we get out so we wanted to
see did they have colony forming units
and what did we get out of of the points
that were then put into culture so we've
got the line lows and they yielded many
colonies the live highs son the dead we
got very view and the intermediates we
got very few so they suggested to us
that the intermediate population or the
unknown population was pretty dead they
weren't recovering when they've been put
into broth and then becoming live they
they were going down into the into the
dead set so you kind of see that
progression chart you're just getting
dead ooh and Edwin don't can you get
so what are the data that likes this
this work has also been published in the
references at the bottom and this is
just shows um what was illustrated
previously from the colony-forming use
new plates but in an in a graph format
with the combined results of three in
three experiments so it shows with the
blue arrows that the intermediates
didn't have any colony forming so very
few colony forming units are after after
sorting so I think that should enable us
to give some highlights from that
experimental example and the small
nozzle enables us to get through many
events and have fewer reports but the
resolution was important so we can
clarify those populations and then sort
them and yes sterility was a big
question that the users after this
something had been run but the
resolution wasn't just in pure essence
was it here because because they are
looking a bacteria the one thing on the
astronauts that we have these multiple
masks for the forward scatter detective
altitudes two floors gas detectors they
can use multiple different masks in and
we can use those to best differentiate
different populations where actually it
may be just Lawson to small and forward
and side scatter plot so not only do you
have a science cat off each off each
laser so you can choose which one
showing your best usually the shortest
wavelength gives the best resolution
usually but you can then combine that
with different master on the forwards
gutter and took quite quite often we
will change those data master and see
which one works best for each sample
type and generally the one master
combination works for most sample types
but for bacterias one that would
actually spare it's been a bit more time
and effort and really optimized so we
can actually get these with a better
gating strategy
yeah particularly when somebody comes
with a new small sample we ask them to
do a little pilot
view on the motor flow first so we can
spend that time getting the resolution
correct with the masks and forward
scattering settings so that we can then
progress on to more speedy sorting there
yeah because you actually came with you
upgrade we've got
better filtering system compared to the
Astros normal and that filtering system
mode enables us to detect smaller
particles compared to the standards
because we know people - down to 40
nanometers yeah
so the yeah the filter is point zero
four yeah so 40 nanometers so then we
can start detecting things like bacteria
we thought I was seeing noise in the
sample just as just debri dust crystals
anything else it may be just a saline
solution and everything else so it
cleans our naming just see back team in
the pool size gets much easier than you
could otherwise and those are the double
detector on the boards gutter really
helps with that so worked example number
five it's actually again more immunology
I've got to say count actually much
better immunologist than I am at this
point that's a technology set
pharmacology type experiments it would
be actually pointing the most recent
work isn't she ask just comes provision
so Karen gon go through thank you
missing huh yeah I finished for coffee
this experiment example it pure tea was
really important because we were taking
the the sample through to proteomics to
look at which proteins were actually
present in in the cells so it's of what
are we doing so is a liver based sample
and this was a model of release myiasis
in mice and so wanted to see which drop
the which cells the drug accumulated in
so the drugs Gibbon and it goes into the
blood and then it goes into their cells
in the liver and then many different
cell types and whatever but which ones
does accumulate in the most and so that
was the premise of this work so we had a
little bit input whole liver through the
mo flow not without disaggregating at
first that was really upset it so the
the liver was digested and one single
cell suspension and then we wanted to
get their different in neurological
subsets distinguished from the liver and
sort them so then we taken down into
mass spec yeah yeah must spend
analysis yes if it's not like analysis
postage by all likely see ministration
actually the cows got here because these
are really sticky cells hi yes they do
like to buy it so they'll stick to
anything and put they stick to each
other and other cells and other bits of
tissue and everything else which means
the size of the individual cell may not
be that big but the size the clamps
which can cause to clumping clogging of
the system and so actually I'm gonna
count Karen tell them to use for these
so we used a 90 micron nozzle for this
but it this comes into questioning of
our users it's often we say to them or
what's the size of the largest particle
in your sample that you want to saw and
they just give you the size of the cell
that they want to sort and so you have
to ask the question again
what is the largest are you sure that's
[Music]
often take their sample when we question
it and put it under the microscope
measure it because it can it's not just
how big is everyone's cell it's had
bigger their clubs and we do encourage
filtering it's not always possible and
even once filtered they can then start
to stick again so I know think of 90 is
a nice yeah we like the oddity so this
is an example of the sort strategy and
logical gating that was used to identify
the lymphoid cells the neutrophils the
monocytes the dendritic cells and the
cut the cells they've been they've been
this sort experiment and this then gave
the success that would then go on for
the for the analysis and the FM own
controls that are shown at the bottom
just as a point of reference and to
bring up any discussion or questions
that somebody might have later but that
was then also put into place which is
really useful when you've got a
multicolored
gating strategy so I think this was a
six color experiment it was certainly
very useful to help set the gates and
verify that we were getting the
population want interest at FMO thank
you it's them presence minus one
flow with her essence make flow a penny
alone no no no no well then we have
enough of those just for teachers on
that so so what did be yes what did the
data look like in terms the bearing
communication and cell sorting so we're
an imaging and cytometry labs so we can
image the sorted cells and this is from
sight of things so you can use the
morphology of the cells that were sorted
to make sure that they have the correct
identification these are shown in the
top panel there by their by their little
thumbnail and morphology print and we
have the flow cytometry post sort data
shown underneath for the populations so
we've got them in the same order as they
were in the previous slides about
lymphoid cells first then your neutrals
the monocytes the gender it excels and
the eyelid colorful cells so again none
of them look 100% you'll know the gates
have been kept exactly the same when you
get a normal distribution off your sort
of populations disagree you always put
the sort population there is the whole
population always tweak the game time so
you're only getting the definite
positives not those aligned with
negatives as well but of course it's
spread back and distribution to some
instrument noise sample noise and of
course you also gain a little bit of
bleaching yes and that's quite evident
in the neutrophil one I think there it
looks a little bit lower down but that's
because it's at and enticing the
efficiency was comforting it's still a
clown yes so it's not like like a
separate population pulled off so very
confident and still and still getting
good purity actors so this example
number five a loser
so John Hannah and the cool case group
need some awesome cell sorting and
downstream metabolomic in this case a
type of work that's we know the
transcriptome you said earlier having
tablets type work on the back of these
and purity was absolutely everything for
that type of analysis so actually just
before we go green ice time he's pushing
we're all eating our lunch now and drank
a coffee so just a few other things that
we really appreciate it with the
astronauts itself it's actually it's
coming becoming mainstream now how in
five six one laser you as you go you
alone you you will start with the four
eight eight days and then we've got a
six three three they're making a for air
five of the five six bar provided kind
of just not that the foreleg tagged us
does because more
and there's zombies better that's a key
bit to increases our standing the deck
size signal-to-noise so it can look at
weak signals much better than the teeth
in the past the negatives of game sight
the flower girl plug it again not so the
size of let's talk we've got some great
data to show just how the signal noise
makes a big difference to what you can
resolve and the usability the other
thing it's great to flexible if you die
choices we can able to use at five six
one laser and you know we're not just
being a typing we're not just you know
fluorescence a lot of our users like
fluorescent proteins as well and so M
cherries and then M rfp's enzymes yeah
Tomatoes pretty today I think so gives
us those possibilities just wouldn't be
possible necessarily on or a tec-9 meat
and laser so we compared the two laser
lines to see if it did make a big
difference on that on the left of your
screen you've got a floor eight eight
nanometer laser and the five six ones on
the right hand side and you can see the
staining index is nearly twice as good
off the five six bottom and the for a
take now notice we use exactly the same
filter in this case not to keep point is
the filters weren't even optimum really
for many this is for a different
combination of dies and but we can
easily change the filters because
actually the filter we're using here is
one that we probably use off the for a
Buckeye member actually pour ventilate
or five six one subtly different off the
two but of course we could just open up
the rack and change a filter across so
you do that to get them again just
change the filter across one more time
I'm sorry yeah it's getting late
so we have that ability to change the
filters readily so you can optimize it
from the best possibility so you can see
that five six one laser can give us a
best ending index interchange because
it'd be even better than that and we
didn't you change filter now to the
other possibilities we've gone off from
a five seven nine straight sixteen we
changed it to definitely different
sample time and again regarding proven
sustaining index but now that
backgrounds higher yet sustaining index
does depend on your sample type that
you're working with also the other
advantage is multi wealth matrix if it's
downs how to do ninety-six barmaids
don't that's training routines do 96
well plate sorting
can do 1536 well plates or team actually
we spent a long time really very fine
it's not improving it is quite difficult
no it's not Rosales now not the cell
sorter that's hard to do it's the image
so it's hard to do so we actually took a
1536 well plates we spotted down the
cell nuclei labeled in each one and then
we looked at all the corners across as
of all the different areas and sampled
across so you can see zone 8 one top
left that each well has a fluorescent
got us a new climb in each well if you
go to see one Tom right now so we've got
NBC's top right you can see them all go
down to the bottom left now manic seem
odd but by look at the second one up on
the far left hand side I can't see any
presence talking necie thinking up so
it's not yeah I have 1536 percent
accurate but when we zoom in on that the
cell is actually there you can see it up
there around 10 o'clock
it does actually it wasn't actually
there so literally every well had the
cell on the 15th Essex you know this is
where we earn our money can you really
have to optimize your system now we're
driving a Formula One car top read
racing car and you know our average user
wouldn't be doing this but it is
possible with care your attitudes so
really the mofo astronauts eat you I
said the start is an example of American
engineering
well done Americans thank you elegant
and simple to use certainly for the
routine stuff it's efficient and quietly
signal-to-noise speed and efficiencies
freely ins and actually I would argue it
is one of the world leaders so I thought
which is why we chose it here at York
but before culture whose bodies get
ahead of themselves he still just a cell
sorter there's a lot of other things in
the world that we also make it written
countryside's flex tool will tell you
what we can do there on that front so is
it the missing link what are we actually
started at all I said how'd you know
Meeks was limited proteomics by fizzy
molecular interactions by
by chemistry Hansen is a biochemist from
trade I may be limited but it's just a
missing link because I would now argue
that this microscopy even exists but we
never quantified plates like Tommy tree
and we can do ourselves sorting upon
that cell sorting we can take into the
genomics proteomics for tableaus
biochemistry you know what we are the
starting point we need to sell sort to
now help and generate a next generation
of genomic and transcriptome it data the
next generation proteomics haploid enter
these techniques are awesome and they're
made even more powerful thanks to cell
sorting yeah its correlating techniques
now not just one in isolation itself so
if I can just advance to the next slide
I'd like to thank actually the team that
are all behind this and you know the
great academic roots here we've got
great environments working really
supportive great users keeps her job
entertaining it does hopefully we meant
to change you as well my team here so
Karen Joey and Graham beg Mukesh all
there but also our users who are
brilliant to work with and give it throw
us really difficult samples to go up so
actually it's nearly time for some Q&A
so I can't wait I hope you got some good
questions to ask us but before you do
there's a couple of questions are better
than cultured but quick survey questions
for you to do so I'll just pass over so
you can do these quick survey questions
now thank you dr. O'Toole and dr. hog
for your presentations a quick reminder
for our audience on how to submit
questions simply type them into the drop
down box located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. O'Toole and dr. hog will answer as
many questions as time permits the first
question is how do you choose the
trigger channel that's going to be very
sample dependence to bacteria to your
knowledge immunological samples this is
going to vary some
I think if it's a small sample like a
bacteria or a small parasite then I'd
probably start with trying to trigger
off in a side scatter parameter start
with the floral tape but maybe also walk
through the other side scatter lays
their options as well and have a look
and one thing I often do is I will then
set it to where I think it should be and
then take it down lower
no we're nowhere and then all of a
sudden you see all the noise and the
electronic noise and you know where to
set set the threshold and then work from
there the key key factor is having
buffer only or diluent only because
sometimes people will give me the the
dilly-o and you'll put it on and you
realize the buffers been contaminated
it's only happened once but ever since
then I always ask for it because that
can be critical when trying to set off
your trigger channel as make sure that
you check it against the buffer as well
so it takes a bit at a time but it's
worth just empirically setting right
working through the options so this is
for any it's even for flow analysis as
well it's relevant to and you say the
users buffer uses buffer can be very
different to the other thing for the
small stuff the bacteria we quite often
put a positive die in there to start
with
yes - doctor we can treat off the
fluorescence and then look at all the
other trigger channels to see what gives
us the best the tease population and
then use that from there onwards yeah
yeah okay that's also the question
that's great thank you
next one is how do you sterilize Nemo
flow so there's there's there's
different options for that we'd
sterilize the mostly every two to three
weeks with ethanol ethanol through the
whole system and leave it overnight if
we can and then flush it all out with
water and then put it back into the
autoclave she threw it we autoclave all
of our she's fluid and just make sure
it's clean as you shouldn't be necessary
to do that but
we are belt-and-brace approach because
some of these are ethically quite
sensitive samples and we just don't want
to give anything to risk so me so we
choose we choose I'll do that because we
have so many different different users
but if we run bacteria through the mode
flow on one day then I like to you know
possible book it out the next day for a
good thoroughly and that will involve on
running bleach through the system and
then water and then putting it back into
chief fluid but also I test it as well I
will take a sterility sample and ensure
that ensure that it is sure that it is
clean but the other option is you can
put a broad-spectrum antibiotic through
the system and leave it just deep
overnight and hopefully get rid of
anything for those um there's quite a
set of procedure of opening valves as
well to make sure that there's nothing
in dead space yeah and to run it through
a high flow rates and sometimes just to
turn it off
yes when you got valve junctions show
you this way you can get dead space is
just behind and the bacteria can hide
behind so it's good just to let things
be able to diffuse over time so actually
weekend's were great time so just shut
it down on a Friday afternoon
put it over forget everything came to
sterility and leave over the weekend and
then come back Monday and hopefully
everything's diffused and died off by
then Christmas is a great time to bomb
it with a antibiotics as well I can
share protocols for cleaning if anybody
really wants to do some happiness
contact aside that sounds imagine yes
that is that was great here's your next
one what is your favorite nozzle I I
think we're gonna be unanimous on this
one two three it's a really nice halfway
house between the 70 and the 100 but we
can run a higher flow rate a higher drop
rate so we can sort faster with a 90
compared to the hundred but they
actually meet the volume is not that
much greater than with the 70 so there
is a compromise Peter nice
halfway house that means we get fewer
blockages better yield recoveries
generally good for samples that can
start to stick that can be valuable in
size it just seems to work really nicely
to me the astronauts may not be
optimized in the 90 but has all these
different nozzles available to us and
definitely it for ourselves and 90s
Gregg but we do use a 70 a lot it's
still faster which is good fast even
though they can't physically run fast
I'd like to run their samples fast
difference between the two can you run
fast no well we have to run fast we may
mess up their sorts don't we so
definitely the 90 I think and these
babies are probably the big ones yeah
fun that's a more challenging always
they go at 90 you have ants to that are
there any other questions yes thank you
for that okay so your next one is do you
allow users to operate the mow flow solo
yes is the answer one or two users can
be super trained he's they're using it a
lot and you know we're not here 24 hours
a day
their science quite often does take
quite a long time yes they have to get
up city hours in the morning but not
even in the morning it's work through
the night to get samples to us to work
through a working day well sometimes
it's gonna take longer than that and
they're gonna have to work through the
night so in some instances they are
fully trained and they can use it
themselves as long as they're competent
that's great a lot of users they we will
start it off for them set it up but then
they can monitor it so we can get on and
do other service work and help other
users they can monitor it and they can
run then Oh sterilize it and turn it off
at the end of the day so certainly
empowerment's do that that any worries
at all yes we coined the phrase tip the
sort so we trained our users often
they're going to be doing along sorts
how to set the sort but we're in the
background and can help with new devices
okay hey thank you a question yes we
have time for one
more question and it is can you comment
on the reliability the instruments he
said more reliable than many of our
users no I'm joking
but ya know the system is super reliable
actually this is cool I can't actually
remember the last time I saw an engineer
so I seem to call out cool he comes once
a year to service it no we have had an
engineer cool house this year but but
that was for a minor thing one it wasn't
broken we just had a nickel with the
door and we just wants the door we
placed it wasn't not working everything
was fine but it was just County place
that I think that's that's cool
okay well I would like to once again
thank dr. O'Toole and dr. Hogg for their
presentations do you have any final
comments yeah I'm still not sure which
is larger slides are new to me
as I was looking through it today and
that's we usually work at the last
minute as always as opposed to rusty
hope you enjoyed it and questions yeah
yeah thank you thank you very much well
thank you again I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speakers afterward we
would like to thank our sponsor Beckman
Coulter life sciences for underwriting
today's educational webcast this webcast
can be viewed on-demand through January
2019 lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye